here's a statistic that might surprise
you 95% of elected officials who seek
re-election in the United States get
reelected just look at this graph that
shows the rate of reelection for members
of the US House of Representatives it
hovers all the way up here it stands to
reason that if you have two candidates
for every office one from each party it
would be about 50% of the time the
candidates would be reelected but it's
so much more than that in this video on
congressional elections I want to talk
about some of the structural aspects
that is the way things are set up in
congressional elections that leads to
this really high number what are the
advantages of being an incumbent that is
the person who already holds a political
office so what kind of advantages does
an incumbent have simply for already
occupying an office well say maybe
there's a Senate race between candidate
green call her Amy green and candidate
Rose maybe he's ten rows now what sort
of advantages might Amy green have just
because she already holds this Senate
seat well one of her advantages is that
she has a staff she has people whose job
it is to answer the phone calls of
constituents make them feel heard they
can do all sorts of things to help her
she also has the advantage of male
members of Congress can send out mail
for free whereas candidate Rose over
here has to pay for staff and pay for
mail alrighty that's a lot of money
the other thing that candidate green has
going for her his name recognition she's
already been a successful candidate
which shows that she knows how to win an
election and there's a lot of advantage
to having name recognition it's its own
kind of advertising are you going to
vote for someone you've never heard of
before or someone who frequently appears
in the media who could be going to local
or state events school openings you get
a lot of face time simply from occupying
a seat and that's free advertising as
well the last aspect is money because of
this incumbency advantage and this is a
little bit of repeating cycle interest
groups lobbyists and others are far more
likely to give money to the candidate
who is already in a position because
they know that candidate is likely to
win and therefore their money is going
to get them access to that candidate who
will hear out their concerns and perhaps
look upon them favorably so it compared
to all of this candidate rose has a
really uphill battle he's got to pay for
a lot of things that the incumbent
doesn't have to he doesn't have the name
recognition or the automatic media
attention and he's viewed less favorably
by the people who might give money he's
a bit of an unknown quantity another
advantage that incumbents have is that
they get to draw voting districts at
least every 10 years in response to the
US Census and changes in populations the
districts and states must be redrawn
politicians do that redrawing and they
tend to use this opportunity to create
safe districts for themselves safe being
districts where the voters who are
arranged geographically will be likely
to vote them back into power those in
power will also
use this opportunity to attempt to harm
their opponents in a process known as
gerrymandering there are two other major
factors that contribute to whether a
congress member is reelected one of them
is in each state the form that their
primary takes some states like Iowa have
caucuses where party members gather to
vote on who their nominee should be
these are very tightly controlled by the
party there are closed primaries where
only the registered members of a party
may vote on their party's nominees for
election and then there are open
primaries where any registered voter can
vote for a party nominee even if they
belong to the opposing party so the form
a state's primary takes has a strong
effect on how tight the party control is
over that process the last factor
affecting congressional elections is
whether or not they coincide with a
presidential election there's much
higher voter turnout for presidential
elections since there's a great deal of
interest in them and money spent on them
and that means that you tend to get a
broader sample of the population more
people are likely to vote so you'll have
a better idea of how the American voting
public is feeling more generally but in
midterm elections which are those
elections that don't fall at the same
time as a presidential election voter
turnout is lower and that means that
it's going to be the really engaged
voters who are often strongly aligned
with a party that will come out
midterm elections also tends to punish
the party in power so when the president
is highly regarded and doing well his or
her party tends to gain seats but if the
president is doing poorly or has a low
public opinion rating then congressional
seats will often go to the opposite
party can see here this chart of net to
gain and loss of the president's party
and in most cases the president will
gain a few followers in the first
midterm election see here George W Bush
2002 his party gained both House and
Senate seats but often in the sixth year
of a two-term presidency voters harshly
punished the president's party you can
see that in george w bush's sixth year
the republicans lost 30 house seats and
six Senate seats and a similar effect
happened with Barack Obama in 2014 the
Democrats lost 13 House seats and nine
Senate seats so there's a strong
correlation with the president's party
and the faith's of members of Congress
who belong to that party